I'm here to do another debunk video on Destiny lying about his
court case. I really liked what Ryan Beard did in his video.
So, I'll be outlining all the flaws and fallacies in Destiny's
argument, exactly what gets under his skin, including personal
details with regards to the identity of Misto, details concerning
Misto's harm and suffering caused uh because of the defendant's
actions and explicit content. So, the personal details, there
are no more personal details. Her name is never used. This the
um the protection of the name is is maintained throughout this
entire hearing. um details concerning the harm and suffering.
She's already publicly filed about all of these and then explicit
content. These things have all been publicly filed. So all of
this is already part of the public record. So this is ridiculous.
But right off the bat, Destiny calls some of Jane Doe's claims
and her request to seal the hearing transcript hilarious and
ridiculous. Straw man appealed to ridicule. He says her wanting
to seal details about her harm or explicit content is ridiculous
because all of this is already part of the public record. public
lawsuit might say she was harmed, but the details shared in a
hearing or a secret witness statement, that's often much more
sensitive. Um, their filings have honestly been so sloppy, I
don't even think they should be granted any protection of the
witness. He said he may likely spend up to $750,000
on his attorney, and he's mocking Pixie's sub $50,000 attorney's
resources. Destiny's attorneys can afford assistants who have
assistance. That doesn't even touch the stupidity required to
spout the logic that he should be able to dox witnesses because
Pixie's attorneys make grammar mistakes in filings
identities at this point. Also, witness identities aren't typically
protected even in these cases, even in these cardi cases because
a witness's identity is not inherently protected thing. Again,
they're coming at this with kind of like internet rules where
your name is sacred and you like, "Oh god, the name is doxing."
But that's I'm sorry. In court, that's just not the case. A person's
name is not generally a protected piece of information. Destiny
already lost this battle. Three witnesses are under seal. He's
just seething. That makes me very happy. Moreover, this contradicts
his statement last week where he said witnesses under seal were
expected and he didn't even fight it that much. There's nothing
wrong with them filing stuff under seal, especially for a case
like this. I think it's appropriate this. I think it's appropriate.
I don't even think they should be granted any protection of the
witness identities at this point. Also, witness identities aren't
typically protected even in these cases. There's nothing wrong
with them filing stuff under seal, especially for a case like
I think it's appropriate this. I think it's appropriate. They
tried to sell it in a way that you expected the underseal filing
motion to not be granted. I think generally
um I don't know if it's that hard to file things under seal and
I'm not sure if we really fought that hard against filing it
under seal. The big So if they file under seal an unredacted
declaration then that means that we have all the information.
Like I'm fine with that. It's fine. You just can't do that. I
don't know why they keep trying to make this argument that they
can
trying to file like you can't like like filing protective orders
for every single witness is just not normal. It's not the ordinary
case of things. Again, if you look at like all the Cardi cases
that have been filed, none of the or at least none of the ones
that I've read, the witnesses aren't uh protected names. The
witness's names are are just there cuz it's part of the case.
There's nothing wrong with them filing stuff under seal, especially
for a case like this. I think it's appropriate this. I think
it's appropriate in a Cardi case where the defendant is publicly
streaming and doxing like this word is not this is just not a
word you use in court.
A name is not doxing for purposes of like a court case and witness
intimidation and harassment are real and ongoing concerns. Yeah,
welcome to the internet. You don't think I get intimidated and
harassed? I'm not direct if I direct any. Well, then sanction
me for it. At this point, you should be praying for me to be
intimidating and harassing targets because it's the only out
you have in any of this. You know, Destiny acts like this isn't
usual or normal, but it was used just the other day in the Diddy
Combs trial. One of his arguments against this claim is, "While
those cases are crazy and insane, the claims are not relevant
to whether witnesses should be sealed. Witnesses can be protected
in white collar crimes and a wide variety of cases. The only
variable is the weight of public knowledge interest with the
potential poisoning of the jury pool due to witnesses not coming
forward or otherwise." The defense has said, "Hey, your honor,
we've complied with the court's order. We have filed a substantially
more redacted version, but we think it's unfair that we have
to. And we think it's unfair that we have to because
if we have to do that, the result will be an unfairly polluted
jury pool manufactured by the government's misleading narrative
and widely disseminated by the press. They say that their
characterization of the evidence that they've reviewed
is appropriate,
that it should not be sealed, and that the court should evaluate
when something is proper to be sealed and that public access
reigns here. I disagree with the defense argument on this because
the protective order, including the sealing order, is already
in place. 6851's purpose is to protect against the publicization
of intimate matters. If you actually read the case where this
protection order was granted, this was just the uh permission
to proceed under pseudonym for the plaintiff. It had nothing
to do with protecting witness identities. So, the citation is
bad and they misited it, but whatever. Fallacy, misleading interpretation.
I'll be honest, I went to chat GPT for the legal citations.
15 USC section 6851 do Williams v. Williams chat GPT analysis
says the cited case underscores the protective purpose of against
the publicization of intimate matters. This protective principle
can extend to witnesses whose testimony involves such matters
and who face similar risks of public exposure and harassment
if their identities are revealed in connection with those details.
Time to file response reply answer as to the opposition comp.
Okay, so we filed a response to their uh order to compel Kiwi
Farms to remove videos. uh because it's just everything about
it is ridiculous. You're not gonna ask them to remove any of
my videos literally just for your client. You're not even ask
for other other women's videos be taken down. You're just literally
just it's and it's it's inappropriate. Kiwi Pharmacist is on
a party to the case. You can't issue a court order compelling
a nonparty to do something. And the requesting of attorney's
fees as a result of it is stupid. A court order to remove something
doesn't prevent it from being reposted in the future. It's just
dumb. Um but
fallacy, whataboutism, and red herring, Pixie is focused on her
specific harm in the videos pertaining to her case. Whether other
videos exist or should be removed is a separate issue. Attacking
the request for attorneys fees as stupid is an ad homonym, not
a legal argument. Pixie's motion is to address the unauthorized
distribution of her intimate images, which is the subject of
her legal claims. I like about court. Okay, this is what I like
about court. We when we go to talk to the judge and when we go
to talk uh in filings, this stuff has to be put here under penalty
of perjury. So, we really have to mean what we say and we have
to say what we mean. Uh Jane Doe has had the opportunity to say
a whole bunch of wild and crazy about me on hering Substack.
Um
so she had the opportunity to say a whole bunch of crazy out
here publicly. This is all public by the way. Um without any
of this being under penalty of perjury, without being in front
of a court. Uh, and then now when I finally get my day in a hearing
to ask questions and respond and to give my perspective on things,
they've demanded for that to be sealed and hidden from the public
despite the fact that her side of the not under oath statements
remaining public, which is ridiculous, but whatever.
It's not whatever. It's actually gross and it's aing abuse of
the system, but okay. Fallacy, false equivalence. Statements
made on a personal blog are different from sworn testimony or
evidence in federal court. Court proceedings have rules and procedure.
The request to seal a transcript is based on the sensitive nature
of the in court testimony and evidence, not just one person's
story. Even if Destiny wanted to make this argument, her one-time
public statement perled with his weekly streams calling the plaintiff
and her council evil, abusive, lawbreaking, would still be wrong.
According to him, defendant erroneously states that this court
lot subject matter jurisdiction over the claims involved in this
action which arise out of federal statute 15 USC 6851 civil action
relating to disclosure of intimate images Images Act card E.
The defendant takes this misguided position based on his claim
that the one and only time he shared this video was prior to
the statute being enacted. Plaintiff has presented this court
with competent evidence that directly rebutts and disproves defendants
assertion. The court has subject matter jurisdiction because
the claims arise under 15
The burden of proof to establish subject matter statute that
they're claiming, which became law on October 1st, 2022, allows
for an individual to file a federal civil suit against anyone
who discloses intimate visual depictions without the consent
of the person depicted. Disclosure is defined as an act to transfer,
publish, distribute, or make accessible. This is a broad definition
and in construing a statute, the court must begin and often should
end as well with the language of the statute itself. So for Cardi
purposes, transfer, publish, distribute, or make accessible.
This doesn't mean you have to do it in a public manner. Sending
it to a single person does count for Cardi stuff. Okay, that's
important because the later uh claims that they site uh do not
count as just singular transfer. You have to publish it on an
internet public website. Okay, but law didn't come into effect
until October 1st, 2022.
I had to doublech checkck this claim with a few people, including
esports Batman, 10-year vet previously of the Destiny community
and attorney IRL, because I thought I hallucinated this double
speak or had to be blinded by bad faith. Listen again.
So, for Cardi purposes, transfer, publish, distribute, or make
accessible. This doesn't mean you have to do it in a public manner.
Sending it to a single person does count for Cardi stuff. Okay,
that's important because the later uh claims that they site uh
do not count as just singular transfer. You have to publish it
on an internet public website. Okay, but law didn't come into
effect till October 1st, 2022.
Here's the rebuttal esports Batman gave.
Keyword is disclosed in or affecting interstate or foreign commerce
or using any means or facility of interstate or foreign commerce
without the consent of the individual where such disclosure was
made by a person who knows that or recklessly disregards whether
the individual has not consented to such disclosure may bring
a civil action against that person in an appropriate district
court of the United States for relief as set forth in paragraph
3. Attached here too is exhibit A is the stipulation of LA LLC
to subject itself to this court's jurisdiction in regards to
the propos order. Cisco court does not does have request relief.
Defendant claims that removing these videos is arbitrary relief
even though he contradically claims that he has tried to have
them removed to no avail and continues to victimize himself with
regards to the alleged damages he is now facing because this
video was posted. I understand it's a court case and you're trying
to win it, but I'm sorry. This is just the most disgusting groy
like just absolutely it's just the most disg
like like even in a court filing. I'm sorry. Like eat this. So
dis. He victimizes himself. He's victimizing himself. Get the
over yourself. What a gross thing to say. Joan won. Destiny lost.
Loser fallacy. Appeal to patchy beard. Straw man voice. Can't
keep spaghetti in pockets fallacy. The relief requested is but
one step towards correcting the wrong caused by defendant to
plaintiff. The wrong that was caused when somebody who wasn't
me uploaded these to a website that I don't control. Give me
a break. While the defendant may be comfortable with having this
type of private content on the internet, like each. Are you serious?
Plaintiff is not and continues to suffer extreme emotional distress
because of the publication of apparently not a concept everyone
but the defendant seems to understand. Like each this case court
case has been for how long, right? You guys were sitting on your
thumbs doing all while apparently your your client was apparently
it took you a month and a half to file for a TTRO that got tossed
in large part because of the stailness because of how long it
took you to file the temporary restraining order. You're telling
me that it took you more work to write up the court the the restraining
order than it did for the complaint? Why wasn't the TRO submitted
the same day or the day after the complaint was submitted? It's
a TTRO. It's an exparte request for enjoining behavior. Why the
are you why are you waiting so long? What we're now 6 months,
7 months, 8 months into the leaks and now you're saying that
there's irreparable harm that's being suffered. How has it taken
so long? Fallacy, victim blaming, ad hominemum, misdirection.
These are personal attacks and attempts to shift blame. The timing
of legal filings can be strategic, and delaying a TTRO request
doesn't negate the harm of Destiny unconsensually sharing Pixie's
videos. Her public statements about her experience are her prerogative,
especially if she feels it's a response to his actions. Pixie's
attempts to seek legal redress and share her experiences are
not victimizing herself, but actions taken to address the harm
allegedly caused by Destiny's actions. The focus remains on defendants's
actions and plaintiff's right to justice. He is spending 7x on
attorneys and ridiculing the plaintiff's attorneys because they
aren't as staffed or have the quality of his attorneys. Additionally,
the defendant is continuously ridiculed in Machmau after the
video was leaked to his followers on his online platforms. It
hasn't I'm not like ridiculing her for the video though. Nice
trying to combine that there. I'm ridiculing them for the behavior
that they're displaying in court, including directing his followers
to the Kiwi Farm site. Again, that's another super gross mischaracterization
of me complaining that all of my revenge is still being openly
hosted on Kiwi Farms. He just did it again. He's telling the
audience where his leaks are, which include other people. He
desperately wants everyone to see his diseased unit. None of
the commentary bros or anybody seem to be talking about it or
give a about it, but okay. Granting this order would be proper
as it would serve to prevent imminent irreparable harm to imminent
and irreparable. They say 7 months into the case. What does imminent
mean? What does irreparable harm mean? The imminent irreparable
harm to that instead of resto's mental health and or quality
of life. Defendant opposes the plaintiff being awarded attorney
fees because he claims there was a failure to me confer. In fact,
even his own attachment to show there was an attempt by plaintiff
to reach a solution to this prior to presenting. Yeah. And you
guys rejected it cuz you wanted to keep my revenge posted on
Kiwi Farms. Cuz you wanted to keep my revenge posted on Kiwi
Farms. He's saying because they didn't want to pay for attorney's
fees to get his revenge taken down. They clearly want it to stay
up. By that logic, Destiny has not only been indifferent to Pixie's
revenge plan, he's also fought her ability to get a court order
to get it taken down, making his actions equivalent to